meanwhile india's struggle with its
kovit 19 outbreak uh
leading it to restrict exports of its
jobs is having repercussions on
the global vaccination effort and
nowhere is that more evident
than on the african continent most
countries there have already
received vaccines via the covax program
which is
working to provide free vaccines to
poorer countries
but the deliveries have been small
relative to population size
and only about 2 percent of the world's
vaccines so far
have been administered on the african
continent
this classroom in the capital of
madagascar has been turned into a
covid19
ward in recent weeks the island nation's
been hit
by a second wave of infections new
confirmed cases
have averaged around double the number
during the first peak last year
the country's health minister attributed
the surge to a more aggressive variant
first detected in south africa and he
announced a health policy u-turn
we had discussions with our scientists
and decided to go for vaccinations
as another way to protect the population
we are now working on this with the
kovacs initiative
the decision represents a change of mind
by madagascar's president
who initially refused to participate in
the kovacs program
he instead promoted a scientifically
unproven remedy
marketed as covet
i think i am convinced i am persuaded
that history will prove us right
there are already two cases that have
been cured with covet organics
but we will see what happens next
the world health organization warned
against its use
before it had undergone proper
scientific trials
and one year on no clinical data has
been made publicly available
to support the president's claims that
the plant-based treatment
can prevent and cure clovid 19.
it is now sold in drinking capsule form
and has been widely distributed in
madagascar
and also exported abroad
when the vaccines arrive madagascar
plans to offer the first doses to health
workers
it will be one of the last countries in
africa to launch a coronavirus
inoculation campaign